okay so uh you guys might hear some
noises going around in the background i
got my dog star with me but uh yeah okay
doctor strange trailer
let's react to this i've been i've been
waiting for i've had to drive here to
the office and everything okay let's
let's let's react to this okay you guys
ready let's react to this
every night
i dream the same dream
the nightmare begins
dude this trailer's nuts
i did what i had to do
[Music]
to protect our world
you can't control everything strange
open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
[Music]
wanda
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
i'm sorry stephen
your desecration of reality
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
just got out of hand
[Music]
you break the rules look out yes
become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
that doesn't seem fair
right
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
okay here's the thing all right
calm down
breathe
i can't though the illuminati sun
man
man i told y'all man the illuminati i
told i told you all the illuminati
that doctor oh my god okay
we got to save this for a trailer
breakdown we got to do a trailer
breakdown but this trailer was legit
there's so
oh
son
y'all ain't ready that's all that's
that's that's
[Music]
y'all ain't ready like this let's just
let's just leave it at that um
this is everything i'd hoped it would be
from like a multiverse movie
and there's
the cameos man
the cameos
just
we'll do a trailer breakdown